foreign
[Music]
decline for somebody I think because of
the Wardrobe and because Prince had his
own style
Rush Hour
it was so much fun man working with
Jackie Chan man this guy he's amazing
man I definitely uh prepared myself
because I knew it was Jackie Chan I
didn't want to you know uh let him down
I worked out lift weights ran you know
the first one uh made sure I was in tip
top shape so whenever he was like come
on you know right I was ready
but he made it so easy man with the
martial arts and all you know stuff he
was just swinging me around basically
just following him man go this way kick
this way look this way made it look like
I knew what I was doing so it was good I
mean one day I think I just walked into
a real police station like through the
back door acting like I belonged there I
was I don't know what I said I don't
remember but I was like this is Carter
you know I gotta go find him you know I
wanted him to be smart he was doing
things his way uh differently you know
and breaking the rules
a lot of the scenes was just off the
script I mean the Improv Jackie followed
me a lot but he was so good the
chemistry was so great man he knew when
I went off on something he was right
there with reaction and all that stuff
and with the action you know he's the
man that with that so I just like what
we're gonna do what you want me to do
he's like just uh just follow me with
the clothes I think back then that was
Versace on The Stylist had me like some
regular like stuff that everybody wear I
was like no no Carter got a little more
edging than this then uh I got this
other stylist who went and got me some
like Versace belt and a couple of
Versace things and the suit was tailored
and man I said this is Carter let's go
in hey
fire to him honey
cut that don't get the clothes okay I'll
pull some items
Little Kim I'll be back
you see that he likes you yeah it was
fun man that was so much fun every time
I go to Vegas and go into the Coliseum
Mall I'll be like that's what the shop
was we we went in and Jeremy was we had
a lot of fun doing that so
[Music]
Friday
break yourself fool
look what you did to my curtain
you better watch when do you climbing
that food before you get blasted on with
what that was my first like star and
roll co-starring role and I was like my
shot to let people know I can carry a
movie uh alongside Ice Cube so I
remember just the preparation focus and
we only like you said we only had two
takes small budget in 20 days working
with Gary gray was great you know smart
you know he really found the great music
for the movie The Great tone I mean he
was just jeans with that and putting it
together it was really just me being you
know the Young The Young Chris Tucker
just I knew I would bring that energy
and then take it up a notch and animated
it a lot and make it fun and funny
[Music]
Craig hold up
a heartbeat man that's what it's
supposed to do and the casting with
everybody with tiny Zeus Lester I don't
know if I mentioned him when he passed
away one of my good friends legendary uh
tiny juice lesson who played Debo
casting him man as like the big villain
coming through like uh the shark you
know from Jaws and working next to Ice
Cube was a pleasure man because Cube you
know uh I was a fan of his being a
rapper the legendary iconic John
Witherspoon and Bernie Mac those guys
comedy Legends and godsmen you had
Ronaldo Ray and Yvette Wilson so many
Legends uh that was in this movie that
passed away and so so uh honored to have
worked with them
Fifth Element
lupusan said he wanted a flamboyant
character and he wanted like sexuality
and all this stuff I thought of Prince I
thought of because Prince was supposed
to play the part decline for some reason
I think because of the Wardrobe and
because Prince had his own style and in
fact he told me one time in person he
heard I was doing the movies I I didn't
want to do it you know I was like oh and
and all that I said okay all right so
then I was the second choice it was
definitely different for me uh but I'm
so so glad I tackled it and did it
because man it brought us you know range
in me I only use probably on stage so
working with Luke bassan man was
unbelievable he we filmed in London he
had all these stages you know at Pine
Woods and it was like he really was you
know in another world and uh man putting
on the outfits and the costumes and all
the stuff man it just really turned me
into a ruby Rod character and I really
was able to just really let loose
[Music]
but I'm so glad I didn't because it was
it's one of my favorite roles I
definitely did some uh different type of
all you know tell them uh to try to make
this that way but they were speaking
French and it kind of gave me the 52
fakes I didn't they did what they wanted
to do but I'm glad they did because
that's what Lupa son wanted and that was
with the character was and it made me go
uh into the character more if I would
have did it my way so I'm glad they
didn't listen to me I love working with
directors uh who write their own scripts
and then they know it from back focus
they can really tell you what they want
and I like when sometimes they dictate
it to me because I could just give it
right at to them
[Music]
Money Talks hold up man wait a minute
wait a minute you that silly ass
reporter from the Channel 5 News ain't
you Channel 12 actually although I knew
it was up man James Russell how you
doing all right what's up well first of
all it was great working with Charlie
Sheen he was man the best and Charlie
actually fought for me to have first
bill in new line wanted Charlie Sheen to
be first building but I kind of brought
the project uh my team brought the
project the new line we found it some
kind of way and then they got uh Charlie
for us and Charlie said no no no he
should have First Billing and I never
forget that you know that he did that
for me early in my career I was slappy
man I would slap the hell out of you you
don't play with me you don't know who
you're messing with I don't even know
when I almost slap somebody my reflexes
just slap people I'd be like damn why
did I do that I don't even know what
I'll be slapping people I don't know
what I'm gonna slap somebody you keep
messing with me I'm dangerous I'm scared
of myself I was just going all out
trying to get the laughs trying to make
it fun I just wanted to bring my energy
to the screen man I was young I just won
every thing to be you know energy a
character was on the run and I just
wanted to just be fun and I was all out
whatever I could you know it didn't
matter I was holding nothing back man
my registration everything what's up man
what's up now the prison scene was
something we came up with on the spot on
that day of because we were so young we
didn't think about it till that day like
we got this I'm right we we're close
friends and and we were really close
back then and we just wanted to do
something that's iconic memorable
because we was like Hey man we got to do
something that's crazy because we can't
let this scene Get By Us
Dead Presidents
all I know is my blood cells all
up
some nights I wake up in cold sweats and
you don't look at me like that man it
ain't the heroine the heroin ain't never
did nothing to me I was happy that I got
Dead Presidents because I want to show a
different range that I could play
dramatic roles early in my career so
that was a lot of fun I was looking
forward to doing that because I did that
right after Fridays I think so working
with the Hughes Brothers was great
because they had the 60s 70s music all
around the setup the whole time man and
they really put us back into that period
man the Wardrobe it was just all the
stuff they put around us man that really
made it work oh move mister
I've been I've been wanting to get next
to you baby you see sometime I have four
moms I say and they had to put these
contacts in my eyes to you know make it
seem like I was passed away for a while
and then I had to walk I remember in
real life I had to walk across this cold
Street in New York I was freezing that
day and I couldn't see anything I think
they had me on with the robe and already
on and I'm walking through traffic to
get to the building where I supposed to
be and I remember that and I was like oh
my God what is this all about
air
the key to Phil is make them afraid
he'll get us both damn fine
Phil got a hundred million dollars in a
life supply of them damn pink nut
hugging jogging shots the hell is he
afraid of
let's say you get feel
how the hell you gonna get Michael my
part wasn't Howard white part wasn't in
the script so my dialogue and my scenes
had to make sense with the script he had
to make the movie move the information
that I gave in the scene had to work for
the for the story and also for my part I
said yes because Ben was like you know
we'll fix it whatever you want to do
we'll we'll make it work I've called
been the player coach because he's an
actor and a director and he knows you
know what it takes you know for actors
to feel comfortable to get the best out
of them and give them that room to do
their thing and great team and it really
had a great time working with them you
got them all there the greatest high
school players in the country
you might have forgot about this but I
was invited best day of my life
then I blew out my damn knee
yeah
they don't matter about what feel is
thinking or anybody's thinking
all that matters is how much do you
believe
I believe in you and Michael said he had
to have Howard in the movie because how
was a big part of Nike Howard was pretty
much the bridge from Nike to uh Michael
I wouldn't have did it without talking
to Howard it was just amazing how it
came about just a blessing because you
know how it's still here how it had a
heart transplant so he he might have not
been here I spent hours on the phone
with Howard white my friend Hal and
talking about you know him and then he
put me on the phone with his childhood
friends when he was five years old and
doing Hot Scotch in the neighborhood
riding bikes to his high school teachers
and coaches High School coaches and
friends all the way up to when they
mentored Charles Barkley so he gave me a
lot all this information and I had to
put it all together and I pretty much
wrote All My scenes I put all that stuff
together and Ben gave me the room to to
do whatever I wanted to do so I I got
all the information and embodied his
spirit and in dialect it was one of the
hardest parts I ever did
Jackie Brown
now you must be out of your mind
if you think I'm gonna get in this dirty
ass truck
we ain't going the weather to Korea Town
man you ain't gonna be in here no more
than 10 minutes man I ain't riding no
goddamn trunk for no minute man well I
can't ride up front with you okay right
up front with me the surprise element is
90 of it I'm sorry man but I ain't
getting no goddamn trunk they put me in
that trunk though I didn't know they was
gonna do me like that in that truck my
fans got mad cause they was like hey we
come to see you in the movie and you get
you know knocked off in the first scene
they got mad at me at that time because
I was like starring in movies and they
wanted to really see me and then they
did it with the strawberry lettuce that
was just every time I hear that song I
think about that scene you know I wanted
to do it because you know Quentin
Tarantino and the hottest directors and
you just wanted to work with him to say
you worked with him so it was fun I knew
it was just gonna be a quick scene I
remember Samuel Jackson working with him
and it was worth it it was a lot of fun
and Clinton you know he was basically
like um you know telling me uh what he
wanted hot because he talked the way he
writes so it's so natural that's one of
the few directors I kind of said his
words kind of word from word because it
was kind of like the way I talk a little
bit yeah
seven Linings
he wrote about you all right but he say
he said you guys was helping each other
out and you were nice and you you had a
mouth on you but whoa whoa whoa okay no
please tell me more about what he said
on the line yeah anything you want to
know I'll just tell you in the letter
was nothing I love movies that I can
learn something from you know mental
health uh is a big big thing and I
learned a lot from doing this movie I
love working with directors like David O
Russell because like I said you know the
script so well he'll tell you to do
something he's off camera throwing stuff
at you he would go around with you like
a monitor and like I say this they'll
throw stuff at you throw stuff that you
throw stuff so I love that you know as a
coming from a comic world
[Music]
When You Love You Rock My World I
remember Tupac just got out of jail we
were filming in the desert he came it
was like unbelievable he brought all
this great energy to the set and we
always having fun because we were
celebrating him getting out to it
Michael Clarke Duncan saved my life I'll
tell everybody that because we were
going over this Doom in the Desmond and
I had my hands up we hit a bump and then
Michael Clarke Duncan grabbed my back of
my shirt of vests and kind of pulled me
back down I think I was going over and I
was like thank you man thank you Michael
thank you so he's all he always got a
special place in my heart
oh look at that
hmm
she looks homeless rock my world was a
mini movie it was a a movie like he
always did it's a lot of fun I think the
theme was we were in Cuba or something
Michael uh Jackson just a part of
everybody's life growing up a big
influence I noticed that you know back
all the way from Fridays I would be
doing a dance or acting or something out
uh sounding like him in a song and in
Def Jam even before that and Def Jam I
did a Michael Jackson joke and then a
lot of comedians in Def Jam everybody
had to have a Michael Jackson joke
because he's just so huge in everybody's
life